or we tend to think of the tech industry
as being at the forefront of tomorrow's
world also leading the way in equality
and diversity among staff it seems
though one European web developers
conference in Germany didn't get that
memo despite promising a rich and
diverse lineup it's canceled looked over
the rent after a number of delegates
objected that no women speakers were
taking part this year's conference seems
to have gone with the white males only
conference lineup shame it's 2019 we can
do better there were numerous speakers
with two sessions myself included a
workshop in the session but no women at
all and not comfortable with that the
organizers have said that only one
female submitted a session proposal
critics say though that those behind the
event should have reached out to more
women we asked our guests for their
thoughts on the controversy the fact is
that women are still half the population
I think we're just marginally over the
half and the people are organizing it
seem to be a group of men it was their
duty their requirement to ensure that
they had a wide range of people to speak
about the issues that they wanted a
debate when you want to be diverse you
know on some occasions will be more
women speakers on some occasions we've
got more men speakers but it's utterly
utterly childish to say that you are
going to have people in and effectively
racially or sexually profile and just
say we're not interesting what your
speech is going to be we're not interest
in your level of talent we're not
interested in the relevancy all we're
interested in is the color of your skin
or your gender that is a joke the point
is not about qualifications the point is
about a culture which I'm sorry to say
you seem to represent which which is
about accusing women of daring to be in
your workplaces that would be a fair
comment if any women had applied no
woman got pushed out one woman applied
there was basically no candidates now
how on earth is that the fault of men
it's very unlikely in the real world
that that somebody would just not want
somebody to speak on the grounds of the
Genda I don't think that's very
realistic I don't think that's something
that's really gonna happen
I don't just don't think it's it's
factually accurate it does happen charm
I'm sorry to say I'm sorry to say it
does happen I'm glad to say it's not
absolutely widespread but don't you may
be in your little haven in which
everything is right and rosy but for
lots of women there are lots of ways in
which women are excluded
however competent they are I'm sorry
that's still happening I wish it wasn't
but unless it's get spoken about I don't
think that much will change
you